[Music]
well hello dear friends welcome to
our program i'd like to know this is a
question and answer program you
send us the questions and then we do
some research
and we answer the questions on the air
uh if we if there is an answer to the
questions and i have with me uh
james rafferty who is associate speaker
for secrets unsealed
and we hope that c.a murray will come
back soon
we are kind of in limbo we don't know
exactly what's going on but
we know that he's in panama and we know
that he's well
okay which is really important um
and you know if you want to send us your
questions
you'll find the address the email
address on the screen
tv some tv.org tv
at some tv dot org send us your
questions we'll be glad to
answer those questions that is if there
is an answer
so i'd like to ask pastor rafferty to
please have a word of prayer
absolutely and then we'll delve into the
questions sounds good let's pray
father i want to thank you again for the
questions that have come in for the
honest
interest that people have in your word
and seeking to understand it better we
want to pray that
those who've asked those questions would
be open and attentive
and be able to hear the biblical answers
that we're able to find for them
and we pray that others who are
listening would also be blessed that
your spirit will guide and direct each
one of us on our journey and our travel
and our
walk with you and we pray in jesus name
amen
okay we have a question here we actually
have four questions that we're going to
try and answer i don't know if we'll get
through them all today but uh we'll do
our best
uh this question is very interesting i
haven't had this question asked of me
ever before
okay uh what what is the angel of death
and the book of death spoken of
in the book the great controversy
and basically what i was able to find
is that the expression angel of death in
the writings of ellen white
is found in only three contexts okay the
first context is
in the egypt where israel was going to
leave
egypt the angel of death actually
marked the firstborn that was the last
plague
coming through right and that's that's
when probation closed
for egypt then it's also used in ezekiel
9.
yes for those who don't have the seal
yes the angel of death comes by
okay and destroys them and the third
time is in the end time those who don't
have the seal of god
again the angel of death will will
destroy them uh ellen white uses
different
uh terms to describe the same angel okay
she calls this the angel of death in
story of redemption 119.
okay she calls it the death dealing
angel
in patrick's in prophets 279 okay
she refers to the angel as the
destroying angel
in desire of ages 51 and in four
testimonies page 20 she calls this angel
the avenging
angel okay uh and then finally uh
in the chapter the desolation of the
earth
which is right before the second coming
of christ or at the second coming of
christ
maybe i can just read this one great
conversation 656
the mark of deliverance has been set
upon those that sigh
and cry for all the abominations that be
done
that's comes from ezekiel 9. now the
angel of death goes forth
represented in ezekiel's vision by men
with the slaughtering weapons to whom
the command is given
slay utterly old and young both maids
and little children
and women but come not near any man who
has
the mark and begin at my sanctuary
says the prophet they began at the
ancient men which were before the house
then she says the work of destruction
begins among those who have professed
to be the spiritual guardians of the
people it's a serious thing to be a
minister
the false watchmen are the first to fall
there are none to pity or spare men
women maidens and little children perish
together and then of course
by extension even though the question
wasn't asked
is does god actually destroy the wicked
or does he simply allow satan to destroy
the wicked
[Music]
so is the angel of death really an angel
of god
a good angel or is the angel of death
one of satan's angels
what do you think well i think it's
pretty clear when you read
revelation 15 16 and onward
that god is directly involved in these
judgments
and as i remember a great controversy
she talks about ezekiel 9 and she
applies that to the seven last plagues
so there's definitely a connection there
i know that there
are the wicked that turn upon themselves
we see that over and over again in
scripture you know where these armies
turn against each other
but ultimately god overrules
the judgment and the punishment that
comes upon
the wicked and the lost and i think he
does that in both cases what i mean by
both cases
is both at his second coming which is
kind of a temporary judgment
you know it's there's still going to be
a resurrection from that and a second
death
and of course he superintends you know
jesus said
this way he said fear not them that can
destroy the body but fear him
who can destroy both body and soul in
hell and i think that's referring to god
there's this statement in great
controversy 6 14
where illinois explicitly says that god
acts in both ways
he allows destroying angels to destroy
and he also uses his angels right
i want to read that a single angel
destroyed all the firstborn of the
egyptians
and filled the land with mourning when
david offended against god
by numbering the people one angel caused
that terrible destruction
by which his sin was punished and then
comes the key portion
the same destructive power exercised by
holy angels
when god commands will be exercised by
evil angels
when he permits yes so i think that's
absolutely clear
yeah and there's a lot of permitting
that takes place you know when god
looses the four winds
there's a lot of permitting that takes
place there but there are angels we're
told that touch buildings
angels from heaven that touch buildings
and the whole building collapses
so i think god still has to superintend
because satan's going to be selective
and god is going to be just and fair
yeah god has a
has a permissive will and a causative
will yeah
and sometimes he allows the devil to
work like in the case of job yep you
know god isn't the one who's doing it
right he's allowing the devil to do it
right
uh you know 2 thessalonians 2 says that
god shall send them
a strong delusion well god doesn't
delude people right
you know but he allows satan to do it
because they've chosen satan as their
leader
they've committed the unpardonable sin
yes and they've turned away from the
truth
you know christ himself became a strong
delusion to the jews
because they refused to accept him and
so he
they they were so deceived that even
when the clearest evidence was given
that he was messiah his resurrection
testified to by roman soldiers pagan
soldiers
they were speechless but then finally
they bribed the soldiers to give a false
report
what more could jesus have done
[Music]
the greatest light in the universe
and yet they rejected the light they
loved darkness more than they love the
light i pray that cannot be said will
not be said about any of us and any of
our viewers
amen okay now uh we go to another
question
this one has to do with 144 000 okay
i am just curious to know from the bible
scriptures
if only the 144 000 will be alive on
earth
before jesus comes or will there be
another faithful remnant group that will
be alive
well i understand that it'll only be the
000 other than the wicked so there's
going to be the wicked and there's going
to be 144 thousands so
you know some teachers is going to be
144 thousand it's going to be a great
multitude
but i think the 144 thousand is
includes all of god's people in the end
of time after the mark of the beast
after abrasion closes they're all in
that one group
that's my understanding yeah i agree 100
and
that's what the bible teaches uh you
know the 144 000 are mentioned
specifically in three contexts in the
book of revelation
revelation 7 1-8 and by the way that
comes immediately after the question in
chapter 6
where the great day of his wrath has
come who will be able to stand
well where would you expect the answer
in the next chapter
[Laughter]
and then in revelation 14 1-5 which
really should be the conclusion to
chapter 13 right the the chapter of
division is in the wrong place because
when you end with chapter 13
uh you know it talks about the beast and
his image and uh you know
everyone in the bar yeah everyone
receives the mark so you you ask the
question well
wasn't there anyone who was faithful so
you go to chapter 14 one through five
yeah the 144 000 were faithful
and then of course you have revelation
15 2 through 4. the numbers not
mentioned but
clearly the characteristics indicate
that this is the same group
they were victorious over the beast his
image his mark and the number of his
name
well that trial is going to be at the
very end of time
so you know that they lived at the very
end of time there is a little intimation
in revelation
13 about people who escape because it
says everyone's going to follow him
whose names are not written
in the book of life of the lamb's name
from the nation of the world but the
specifics are in revelation 14 1-5 the
group is not described right
in other words in revelation chapter 13
well uh you know i think that that
pretty much answers that question
i would hope that it's satisfactory
somebody asked a question and maybe i
can just answer this one because
uh the answer is found uh in one
my daniel notes um the question is
about daniel chapter 8.
the interpretation of the four horns
that come out of the head of the
of this um he goat
the you know the four and then it's
divided into four
and so i'll just mention for the person
who asked the question about the four
horns
in daniel 8 you can read
the notes on daniel study notes that i
wrote
pages 293 to 304 where i deal
specifically with that
particular point let's go to our next
next question in revelation chapter 12
you have a reference to the earth
helping the woman
and so the question is what does the
earth
represent there and how does the earth
help the woman
well you know in revelation 12 as well
as in revelation 13
the earth designates a place that is
opposite of the sea
and the sea represents people's nations
multitudes and tongues populated places
in the earth and we see that in daniel
chapter 7
so the earth would represent a less
populated area of the world
we as adventists have always believed
based on revelation
12 that the woman fled to the earth and
the earth helped the woman and swallowed
up the flood of persecution
that the dragon cast out of his mouth
toward the woman and revelation 13 11
where another beast
government power nation rises up out of
the earth that the earth would represent
the american continent
not the nation itself but the continent
out of which the nation rises
sometimes people get confused because
they think oh the earth is america
no the earth is the continent the earth
is the land just like the seas represent
the nations of europe but not
necessarily the powers of the countries
of europe
right and so we understand the earth
being distinct
from the nation or the beast itself that
rises up out of the earth if that makes
sense yeah so basically revelation 12
verse 16
is speaking about the territory of the
united states
that gave a place for for the persecuted
in europe to come
to the territory because when the
pilgrims came here there was no united
states
right the united states becomes the
united states when you have the
declaration of independence
the constitution and the bill of rights
1787 and 1791
so there was no united states when the
pilgrims came
to this continent right so in revelation
chapter 12 verse 16
it's talking about the territory
giving refuge to the persecuted ones in
europe
but then revelation 13 verse 11
it's referring to the nation itself
because a beast represents a nation
right
and there you have the two founding
principles right which are republicanism
and protestantism
which is a state without a king and a
church without a pope
good basically yeah i love it yeah
separation of church and state
the founding principles of the nation's
landline principles
yes and ellen white states that these
two principles
are the secret of its power and
prosperity
she says that if ever these principles
are repudiated
national apostasy will be written in the
books of heaven
and national ruin will follow and we see
that
predicted in revelation 13 11 when the
the lamb-like power begins to speak like
a dragon
yeah and the dragon of course represents
satan satanic principles
satan gives power to the beast and the
uh this country will make an image to
that
power and so we see all those principles
predicted to be repudiated i think we're
on track right now
fast track for that to be happening and
everything that the beast from the earth
does it does to please the first beast
[Music]
it it
causes everyone to worship the first
beast everything it does it does in the
presence of the first beast
it makes an image of the first beast and
to the first beast
it enforces the mark of the beast it
also does miracles in the presence of
the beast according to revelation
19. so it seems like the the destiny of
this nation
is to help the first power yes recover
the power that it lost in 1798
so the beginning of that transformation
i will say the beginning of it but we
know that transformation has been taking
place for quite a while you know when
when ronald reagan was president he
connected with
john paul ii up in alaska
and they decided to work together it's a
clandestine operation to
try to undermine the ussr and bring down
communism
one of the first problems that ronald
reagan faced when he
connected with the pope to accomplish
this
was that the united states of america
had never had an ambassador to the
vatican
and it was part of the founding fathers
desire not to have an ambassador in the
vatican and so he changed all that so
the first time we ever established
an ambassador to the to the vatican was
under ronald reagan
yeah and harry truman i think it was in
uh he uh had the idea of uh
establishing an ambassador and there was
such an outcry
that he gave up the idea so things have
really changed now you know because now
we have a
ambassador to the vatican and they have
their nuncio which they call their
ambassadors
here in the united states but you know
the closer the united states reflects
the principles and priorities of the
papacy
the more dangerous the situation becomes
and i think as i look
at what's happening in the united states
now definitely
everything that is happening is a
reflection of what
pope francis the first really wants yes
absolutely
in other words the the administration's
priorities now
are the same priorities that the vatican
has absolutely we see this
so and we're not politically correct on
this program so of course
okay so i i think that that question has
been pretty much answered now this last
question
probably is going to take us the rest of
the time at least and
this is the question how do i give my
life to christ
how do i surrender my life to christ
completely
i know the theory and the knowledge
but what are some practical steps i can
take to do that
um you know this is a huge question i
have 12
answers to this question on my on my
paper and i keep thinking of more
you know practically speaking there's so
much that can be done one of the things
that i've always appreciated
um in the spirit of prophecy is a couple
of prayers that i've actually memorized
that i think are so
practical in the way that they help us
to surrender to christ one of them's in
christ object lessons page 159
and that prayer goes like this lord take
my heart for i cannot give it
it is thy property keep it pure for i
cannot keep it i cannot keep it for thee
save me in spite of myself my weak
unchrist-like self mold me fashion me
raise me into a pure and holy atmosphere
where the which current of thy love can
flow through my soul
that's how my journey with christ began
i got on my knees and i just prayed that
kind of a prayer
and asked christ to come into my heart
the mistake we can make and
and i'm just speaking to this question
right now is that we can think that
that's a one-time experience or even a
once a day experience
and it's not the bible is very clear
that it's a continual experience that
word is used
all through the sanctuary service all
through the old testament
to talk about and describe our
relationship with jesus christ
our abiding relationship with jesus so
the first thing i would say is
the way that we do this is we actually
surrender we actually give our heart to
the lord we actually ask and give him
permission to take our hearts
to purify our hearts and to lift our
hearts to heaven
well you know jesus said that we need to
take up our cross
and follow him the apostle paul said i
die daily
he didn't say i die monthly or i died
or i died once upon a time he says i die
daily
because the battle itself is a battle
that takes place
without any without any interruption yep
it continues on right yeah and uh and so
you know there there are several
practical
things that that we can mention when it
comes to
gaining the victory over sin and
committing our lives to christ
and that is one of the things is uh
what are we watching and what are we
listening to yep that's on my list
is that you know because because
what we watch and what we listen to
strengthens
the way we are in other words if we have
a worldly heart
and we're watching worldly things we
become more worldly we do
on the other hand if we are committed to
christ
and we're in the word and we're applying
it to our lives
we'll be more like christ amen you know
it's just like what we eat
makes us what we are what we eat
spiritually
makes us what we are as well in terms of
our spiritual nature
okay since you brought that up let's
just touch on daniel chapter one
food and drink of babylon i was in a
home and i've been in many adventist
homes where
they're pretty strict about what they
watch what they watch they've got
televisions and all they watch is the
news
[Laughter]
there's nothing no good news these days
and i was in this home
where this was happening first thing in
the morning and
you know there was a question that was
brought to me about you know
spirituality and having
closer walk with and i said well i'd
like to challenge you to turn the news
off
don't even watch the news let's cut off
all the food and drink of babylon for 10
days now
his response and i've had a lot of
people respond this way is oh what would
i do without the news you know how would
i survive
and my response to that is that
indicates to me that you are addicted
to something that is not spiritually
good for you if you can't even give it
up for 10 days
that's a problem and as soon as i said
that they said okay we're going to give
it up for 10 days and you know what 10
days turned into 10 weeks and 10 weeks
turned into 10 months
and what i found is is that the news
nowadays
is just like the soap operas used to be
back in the day it's
it's developed in such a way that you
get hooked
and i've experienced this myself where
i'm just trying to keep up with things
but i'm just going from one thing to the
next i'm trying
and pretty soon 10 minutes turns into 15
minutes turns into 30 minutes turns into
an hour turns into two hours
and then i'm talking about it with other
people and they're giving me their
opinion pretty soon
it's consuming precious time that we
could spend in the word of god
so my challenge to people to this
questioner and
others is what like you said what are
you spending your time beholding
maybe you think it's okay but maybe it's
having a detrimental effect
or maybe it's pushing out the time you
need in the word of god
absolutely true maybe we can read psalm
119 verse 11.
it's a very well-known verse okay
it gives us the secret what we've been
talking about
psalm 119 and verse 11.
and by the way the news today is not
really news
yeah it's very much slanted you know no
matter
you you can go to very liberal
to very conservative both of them are
slandered they're not giving you the
news
right they're giving their their
perspective of the news yes
so anyway psalm 119 and verse 11.
uh what does it say you want to read
that sure
thy word have i hid in mine heart that i
might not sin against thee
there's the principle and paul expressed
it as
beholding as an emir the glory of the
lord
we are being changed the word
metamorphosis
in greek okay you know what what
similarity is that between a caterpillar
and a butterfly
[Music]
so so as we behold christ
we go through a metamorphosis through a
transformation and the more we
contemplate him
the more we become like him so ellen
white talks about this idea of taking
your bible with you wherever you go
where you have a doctor's appointment
when you're sitting waiting for an
engagement
open the bible and read a verse bring it
to your memory
and think about it and meditate on it
and you know it's so in
in you know handy right now we can get
our bibles on our apps on our phones we
can take them we don't have to carry
them with us big bulky bible we can take
them anywhere
but i think it'd be good to follow that
council because sometimes what we do
is we spend maybe an hour in the morning
or sometime in the morning
and then we're done and the rest of the
day we spend doing all the secular
things and we don't realize
like it's like trying to eat breakfast
in the morning and
be sustained by that for the rest of the
day you know i think it would be great
for us to follow that council so that we
can get a little bit of more nutrition
in the mid morning a little bit more
nutrition in the afternoon a little bit
more nutrition in the evening
continue to feed on the word of god
amen you know there's another couple of
things that i
i have here what i call the triangle of
sanctification
bible study prayer and witnessing
what more do you have on your list do
you have you have 12 what was 12
10. there's a few more here why don't
you
give us some practical pounds i like
that i like what you're saying there
so the other one was revelation chapter
3. jesus is standing outside the door
and i think a lot of times we're not
letting him into the heart because we
have some concealed sins
so there are things that god wants to
clean out and only he can clean
out and we have this idea that when i
get my closet cleaned out when i get
my house cleaned out that's when i'm
going to let him in well the guy who
cleaned out his house
seven unclean spirits came back there's
no way we can clean out our house
we need to let christ in and then let
him do the cleaning and when the devil
comes he can answer the door and once
you've cleaned it make sure you fill it
yes exactly christ
that's right so we need to have jesus
empty our hearts from evil and then
fill our hearts with the good yes all
right what are some other things you
have there
well another one is i claiming the
promises of god
and many times we go to the bible and
we're looking for what god wants us to
do or we're not even sure how to
navigate it so
i'd like to say as uh as soon as you get
up in the morning or or any time that
you're
you know getting to the word of god find
a promise that you can claim
put your name in that promise ask god to
fulfill that promise for you in your
life
so that it's more practical and look for
him to fulfill that promise
in your life and then another one is
thank and praise god
so when i get up in the morning the
first thing i do basically is i have
some prayer time and then i go to the
word of god i find a bible verse and i
start thanking him for whatever
whatever's in that bible verse
you know one of the verses i read
recently was you know
blessed are they that endure temptation
for when they are tried they shall
receive the crown of life whom the lord
will give to those who love him i
thought thank you lord for blessing me
in order to endure temptation thank you
lord for the crown of life that you're
going to give me thank you lord for
so we just go to the bible you just
start praising god and thanking god and
you know
satan can't stand it when we're praising
the lord he cannot handle
listening to us praising god do you do
it audibly
sometimes because i feel you know i
don't know how to say it
you know there's there's a war going on
around us and if our eyes could be open
we would sense
good and evil angels all around us and
i'm aware of this simply because i know
it
so there are times when i want to speak
out loud and i think it's important for
us
if we have a place you know we don't
want people to think we're crazy you
know so if you want to
play in a hotel or somewhere in public
you know
the thing is these days people are
walking down the street
and they're talking away because they
have the
earphones it used to be that people
would say that person needs to be in the
night
but but these days i think even if you
were praising the lord they would think
you're talking we could get away with it
absolutely another one here i think
that's important is journaling with god
you know when you're going through a
trial bring it to god's attention
ask him for help and talk about it with
him write it out and talk about with him
and ask him to guide and lead you and
help you and then to lead you through
bible promises
and see how he does that and write down
answers to the way he's helped you to
navigate that trial
it definitely does you know it helps to
see
and to hear and to write well
unfortunately our time is up it flies by
on this program
we want to thank all of you for joining
us for i'd like to know
once again i want to remind you where
you can send your questions it'll be on
the screen
tv at some tv dot org
once again tv at some tv dot org
thanks for joining us god bless you hope
to see you next time
and i'd like to know
[Music]
you